the pros and cons of humor and
meme so in some sense
meme there's like a wisdom to
memes um what is it the Magic Theater
what book is that from Hermon has a um
steppen wolf I think but there there's
a there's a kind of embracing of the
absurdity that seems to get to the truth
of things m but at the same time it can
also decrease the quality and the rigor
of the discourse yeah do you feel the
tension of that yeah so initially I
think what allowed us to grow under the
radar was because it was camouflaged as
sort of meta ironic right we would sneak
in you know I deep truths within a
package of humors and humor and memes
and what are called posts right um
and I think
that was purposefully a sort of
camouflage against those that um seek
status and do not want to it's very hard
to argue with a cartoon frog or
a a a cartoon of an Intergalactic Jeff
Bezos um and take yourself seriously
yeah and so that allowed allowed us to
grow uh pretty rapidly in the early days
but um of course like that that's you
know essentially people get steered
their notion of the truth comes from the
data they see from from the information
they're fed and the information people
are fed is determined by
algorithms right and really what we've
been doing is sort of uh engineering
what we call High mimetic Fitness uh
packets of information so that they can
spread effectively and carry a message
right so it's it's kind of
a a vector to Spread spread the message
and and yes we've been using sort of
techniques that are optimal for for
today's algorithmically Amplified
information Landscapes um but I think
we're reaching the point of you know
scale where we can have serious debates
and serious conversations and um you
know that's why we're considering doing
a bunch of debates and having more
serious long form discussion because I
don't think that um the timeline is
optimal for sort of very serious
thoughtful discussions it get you get
rewarded for sort of uh polarization
right and so um even though we started a
movement that is literally trying to
polarize the the tech ecosystem um at
the end of the day so that we can have a
conversation and find an Optimum
together I mean that's kind of what I
try to do with this podcast given the
landscape of things to still have long
long form conversations but there is a
degree to which uh absurdity is fully
embraced in fact this very
conversation is
multi- uh level absurd so first of all I
should say that I just very recently I
had a conversation with Jeff
Bezos and uh I would love to hear
your Beth
Jos opinions of Jeff Bezos speaking of
Intergalactic Jeff Bezos uh what do you
think of that particular individual whom
your name is inspired yeah I mean I
think Jeff is really great I mean he's
built one of the most epic companies of
all time he's leveraged the techn
capital machine and techn capital
acceleration
to give us what we wanted right we want
uh quick delivery very convenient at
home low prices right he understood
how the machine worked and how to
harness it right like running the
company uh not trying to take profits
too early putting it back putting
letting the system compound and keep
improving and you know arguably I think
Amazon's invested some of the most
amount of capital and Robotics out there
um and certainly with the birth of AWS
kind of um enabled the sort of tech boom
we've seen today that has paid the
salaries of you know
I guess myself and all of our friends to
some extent and so I I think we can all
be grateful to you know Jeff and he's
one of the great entrepreneurs uh out
there one of the best of all time
unarguably uh and of course the the work
at Blue origin similar to the work at
SpaceX is trying to make humans and
multiplanetary species
which seems almost like a bigger thing
than the capitalist machine or it's a
capitalist machine at a different time
scale perhaps yeah I I think that um you
know companies they tend to optimize you
know quarter over quarter maybe a few
years out but individuals that want to
leave a legacy can think on a
multi-decadal or multi-century time
scale and so the fact that some
individuals are such good Capital
allocators that they unlock the ability
to allocate capitals to goals that take
us much further or much further looking
you know elon's doing this with SpaceX
putting all his Capital towards getting
us to Mars um uh Jeff is trying to build
blue origin and I think he wants to
build O'Neal cylinders and get industry
off Planet uh which I think is brilliant
um I think you know just overall I'm I'm
for billionaires I know this
controversial statement sometimes but I
think that uh in a sense it's kind of a
a proof of stake voting right like if
you you've acquire if you've allocated
Capital efficiently you get you unlock
more Capital to allocate just because
clearly you know how to allocate Capital
more efficiently which is in contrast to
politicians that get elected because
they speak the best on TV right not
because they have a proven track record
of allocating taxpayer Capital most
efficiently and so that's why I'm for uh
capitalism uh over say giving all our
money to the government and letting them
figure out how to allocate it so yeah
why do you think
it's a viral and a popular meme to
criticize billionaires since you
mentioned billionaires why do you think
there's quite a
widespread
criticism of of people with wealth
especially those in the public eye like
Jeff and Elon and Mark Zuckerberg and uh
who else Bill Gates yeah I think a lot
of people would instead of trying to
understand how the techn capit capital
machine works and realizing they have
much more agency than they think they'd
rather have the sort of victim mindset
I'm just subjected to this machine it is
oppressing me um and and the successful
players clearly must be must must be
evil because they've been successful at
this game that I'm not successful at but
you know I've managed to get some people
that were in that mindset and make them
realize how the techn capital machine
works and how you can harness it uh uh
for your own good and and for the good
of others and by creating value you
capture some of the value you create for
the world and and that sort of positive
sum mindset shift is so potent and
really that's what that's what we're
trying to do by scaling eak is sort of
unlocking that higher level of agency
like actually have you're far more in
control of the future than you think you
have agency to change the world go out
and do it you have per here's permission
each individual as agency uh the motto
keep building is often heard right what
does that mean to you and what does it
have to do with Diet
Coke well by the way thank you so much
for the Red Bull it's it's working
pretty well I'm feeling pretty good
awesome um well so so building
Technologies and and building it doesn't
have to be Technologies just building in
general um means you know having agency
trying to change the world by
creating let's say a company which is a
self-sustaining
organism uh uh that you know
accomplishes a function in the broader
techn Capital machine to us that's the
way to achieve change in the world that
you'd like to see rather than say
pressuring politicians or creating
nonprofits that you know nonprofits once
they run out of money their function can
no longer be accomplished you're kind of
deforming the market artificially
compared to sort of
subverting or chusing the market to or
or dancing with the market to to
convince it that actually this function
is important adds value and here it is
right and so I think you know this is
sort of the way between the sort of
degrowth like ESG approach versus say
Elon right the degrowth approach is like
we're going to manage our way out of a
climate crisis and Elon is like I'm
going to build a company that is self-
sustaining profitable and growing and
it's we're going to innov our way out of
this dilemma right and and we're trying
to get people to do the latter rather
than the former at all
scales Elon is an interesting case so
you are a proponent you celebrate Elon
but he's also somebody who has for a
long time warned about uh the dangers
the potential dangers existential risks
of artificial intelligence how do you
square the two is that a contradiction
to you it is somewhat because he's very
much against regulation in many aspects
but uh for AI he's he's definitely um
you know a proponent of of regulations I
think I think overall you know he saw
the dangers of say open AI you know
cornering the market and then getting to
have the Monopoly over uh the cultural
priors that you can embed in these llms
that then you know as as llms now become
the source of Truth for people then you
can shape the culture of the people and
so you can control people by controlling
LMS and he saw that just like it was the
case for social media uh if you shape
the function of information propagation
you can shape people's opinions he he he
sought to make it competitor so at least
like I think we're very aligned there
that you know they the way to a good
future is to maintain sort of
adversarial equilibria between the
various AI players um I love to talk to
him to understand sort of his thinking
about uh how to make a you know how to
advance AI going forwards I mean he's
also hedging his bets I would say you
know with neuralink right I think if he
can't stop the progress of AI you know
he's building the technology to emerge
so you know uh look at the actions uh
not just the words but well I mean
there's some degree where being
concerned maybe using human psychology
being concerned about threats all around
us is a
motivator like uh it's an encouraging
thing I operate much better when there's
a deadline the fear of the deadline like
and I for myself create artificial
things like I I want to create in myself
this kind of anxiety as if something
really horrible will happen if I miss
the deadline I think there's some degree
of of that here because creating AI
That's aligned with humans has a lot of
potential benefits and so a different
way to reframe that is if you don't
you're we're all going to die it just
seems to be a very powerful
psychological
formulation of the goal of creating
human allign AI I think that anxiety is
good I think like I said I want the the
free market to to create aligned AIS um
that are reliable uh and I think that's
what he's trying to do with uh xai um so
I'm all for it what what I am against is
sort of um
stopping let's say the open source
ecosystem from Tri thriving right by
let's say in the executive order
claiming that open- Source LMS or dual
use Technologies and should be
government controlled then everybody
needs to register their GPU and their
big matrices with the government and I
think that extra uh friction will
dissuade a lot of Hackers from
contributing hackers that could later
become the the researchers that uh make
key discoveries that uh push us forward
right uh including discoveries for AI
safety and so I think I I just want to
maintain ubiquity of opportunity to
contribute to Ai and and to own a piece
of the future right it can't just be
legislated uh you know behind some wall
where only a few players get to play the
game I mean so the eak movement is often
sort of
caricatured to mean sort of uh progress
and Innovation at all
at all cost doesn't matter how unsafe it
is doesn't matter if it cause a lot of
damage you just build build cool as
fast as possible stay up all night with
the diet
coke uh whatever it
takes I think I guess I don't know if
there's a question in there but how
important to you and what you've seen
the different formulations of eak is
safety is AI
safety I think again I think like if
there was no no one working on it I
think I would be a proponent sure of it
I think again our goal is to sort of
bring balance and obviously a sense of
urgency is a useful tool right to make
uh progress it hacks our dop energic
systems and gives us energy to to work
late into the night I think also having
a higher purpose you're contributing to
right at the end of the day it's like
what am I contributing to I'm
contributing to the growth of this
beautiful
machine so that we can seek to the Stars
that's really inspiring that's also a
sort of uh neuro uh hack so you're
saying a safety is important to you but
right now the landscape of ideas you see
is AI safety as a topic is used more
often to gain centralized control so in
that sense you're resisting it as a
proxy for centralized gaining
centralized control yeah I I I I just
think we we have to be
careful because um you know safety is
just the perfect cover for sort of
centralization of power and covering up
eventually corruption I don't I'm not
saying it's corrupted now but it could
be uh down the line and
really if you if you let the argument
run like there's no amount of sort of
centralization of control that will be
enough to ensure your safety there's
always more n n n of PE safety that you
can gain you know
99.99999% safe maybe you want another
nine oh please give us full access to
everything you do full surveillance and
and and frankly those that are
proponents of AI safety have proposed
like having a global
panopticon right where you have
centralized perception of everything
going on and to me that just opens up
the door wide open for a sort of Big
Brother 1984 like scenario and that's
not a future I want to live in cuz we
know we have some examples throughout
history when that did not lead to a good
outcome
right